So, take a wild success like Airbnb that everybody knows about.
Well, that company was famously passed on by many smart investors 'cause people thought,...
"No one's gonna rent out a space in their home to a stranger."
Of course, people proved that wrong.
But one of the reasons it succeeded,...
...aside from a good business model, a good idea, great execution, is the timing.
That company came out right during the height of the recession...
...when people really needed extra money.
And that maybe helped people overcome their objection...
...to renting out their own home to a stranger.
Same thing with Uber.
Uber came out, incredible company, incredible business model, great execution, too...
..but the timing was so perfect for their need to get drivers into the system.
Drivers were looking for extra money.
It was very very important.
Some of our early successes, Citysearch, came out when people needed web pages.
GoTo.com, which we announced actually at TED in 1998,...
...was when companies were looking for cost-effective ways to get traffic.
We thought the idea was so great,...
...but actually, the timing was probably maybe more important.